here we go whoo look at this arrangement
look at this sad guy right here sad got
in the corner I like this is actually
hang on this guy's unprotected so so too
is this guy and actually the a and B
ponds are unprotected this one is
accessible to a queen I like this as a
start and then Knight c3 let's yeah I'll
do that um I i held back a little bit
because I was seeing I'm opening up this
diagonal towards my king bishop here so
mmm pawn push
do this I'm weakening this square a
great deal but I saw maybe some line
where if I develop my Knight to c3 and
there's this pawn push maybe I could
take twice but then rook takes King
takes I'm on castled so no thanks on
that so let's get more development here
and if I'm to castle well I could castle
right now Queen side in fact I could
have castled both of us could have
castled clean side on her very first
move which is pretty neat maybe I want
to get in this advance so my night to
see to I think I like that and Who am I
going to do at my dark squared bishop
hmm let's see about this what do we do
computers going a little crazy crazy
town my computer my laptop okay um this
is a three minute game note to self and
poof pawn push well I can't do that now
can I and I can't move this guy says uh
this is a pain this is officially a pain
however could i just kick this Bishop
around maybe I want to do that tell me
get out of here
let's give it a shot get out of there
Bishop back up here i'm probably going
to press forward again gain some space
and a tempo you have to be cautious
because this diagonal is a bit more week
and if you know but ok let's do this
right away if I played the b3 I'm
reinforcing out another light square is
this exposing my king a bit too much if
I open up the position with d4 I don't
think their king is any better off so
let me do that this night is covering
eight to this night is stuck I should
take there and I need development where
is that development i need to get my
queen oh she's not she's not coming out
anytime soon maybe this reinforced my
Center allow my queen to come out if you
get both the bishops out and queen
that's my number one priority at this
point probably Bishop here Queen to one
of these two whew what a pain what a
pain that night's gonna hurt me I could
feel it all right let's do this I'm
gonna take that night he's got to go I
cannot deal with that night sitting
right here whoa oh hang on I could do
the same I forgot I had that available I
was ready to like run that was my first
stop let's not run let's remember that
you can castle like that and this is
just super scary is anyone else scared I
am
just develop what's a matter just
develop King here here is he really
gonna to grab that pun better not how
would I grab here man why this position
just move I'm dropping this aren't I
don't why to give that up maybe I could
push here in response ah the bishop will
come back here though I'm down upon I
need more development all right this is
gonna be okay oh man oh man what can you
do and you start doubling my rook needs
to do something else this night isn't
doing anything but oh no like my night
isn't doing anything special either I
think I have to try that break stuff
open and oh wait a second wait a second
I've seen something that might be a
pretty decent or not ah where's my time
where is it let me take this night out
oh now I'm seeing something maybe clean
check they must be scared are they
scared I'm getting this pond oh and the
bishop may be the King has to run for
the hills he'll runner hill around her
time oh is this gonna be dangerous
um 12 seconds time edge discovered
tricks this is me this is leading to
mate isn't it no it's not I get a fork
though I here I'll discover tricks King
is going quick pre-move time pre moves
pretty moves cleans coming off move why
am I not moving oh I had a queen trade
they don't have time man I went too fast
I like three minute Fisher random but I
like three minute Fisher random I need
five there's so much thinking that needs
to be done in the beginning ah well
that's my preference I guess 55 instead
of the three when it comes to the Fisher
random alright good game been koji let's
go back and let's flip let's see um is
there any reason why not to go here I
wonder like symmetrical English yeah
just judging by the pond alone hmm i
don't know i mean c6 wasn't bad i like
e5 focusing right on that weakness d for
that i created with these first two pond
advances could maybe devise a plan
around sinking at night in there maybe
let's see three the queen is out the
bishops focusing on the weak point and
maybe I'm just over extending here man
it got really scared I think there's I
think there's something good for black
yeah this is that scared me the castle I
forgot I had that and now from here
what's going to be a better move okay
Bishop there i think is fine you're up
upon maybe this maybe there's something
better here hmm
although I guess this is maybe a bit
annoying I could take this night out
just felt like there was something
better for for black here oh now now
okay now there's a lot n of forcing
moves I get that check okay can't be
good for black where's the improvement
where is that improvement hmm maybe it
wasn't a good idea to grab that pond or
instead of bringing the bishop there
might it have been better to just take
on d5 mmm right with you know the follow
up being d for you know if pond takes
and I grab that Bishop pawn push hitting
the Queen and you're on this ok I guess
I could come over to 83 though to defend
maybe it's not so great i actually just
had a blind spot right there a
miscalculation I was just thinking that
after i take on d5 and the night takes
that i could press forward with d4 and
it would be a fork that's not the case
it's the night that's this night that's
recapturing but um so is it really
turning out that the grabbing of that a
to pond turns out to be maybe a bit of
poison hmm or is something like Bishop
here with the thought of maybe taking
out the night and then grabbing this
pond maybe that's better huh yeah maybe
there's something to Bishop here instead
it's tough call these uh I've had setups
like this in Fisher and where the bulk
both the night started out on the I'm
just like in the one corner like that
like an a.a b 8 a 1 B 1 but enough
experience to really know how to play
about with them maybe just not grabbing
on a two what if if this is wrong what's
maybe something that's a bit better how
about maybe jumping that night right in
there and picking up on the bishop hair
maybe maybe it's better to do that night
c4 and I'm pretty sure I just want to
get rid of that night he seems like he'd
kill me if I let him sit there for any
amount of time so maybe that's an
improvement Knight takes bishop takes
Bishop takes I don't know not able to
offer really a whole lot this
arrangement good game though very nice i
love the fisher randoms okay